(whoosh)
This program is a presentation of UCTV
for educational and
non-commercial use only.
(upbeat music)
- Welcome to a Conversation with History.
I'm Harry Kreisler of
the Institute of International Studies.
Our guest today is Neil Shubin
who is Provost of the Field Museum
as well as Robert R. Bensley,
Professor of Organismal
Biology and Anatomy
at the University of Chicago,
where he serves as Associate Dean.
He's the author of the
book Your Inner Fish,
a Journey into the 3.5
Billion-Year History
of the Human Body.
He's visiting the Berkeley campus
as the Hitchcock professor
in the spring of 2009.
Neil, welcome to Berkeley.
- Thank you.
- Where we born and raised?
- I was born and raised in Philadelphia.
- Aha, and looking back, how
do you think your parents
shaped your thinking about the world,
the universe, I should say.
- Yeah my folks, I mean, my
folks encouraged curiosity
and that was the biggest thing in me.
I was a sort of kid who
had a new hobby every week.
I would want to telescope one week,
rock hammer the next week,
it was always science,
and they encouraged me
exploring in a lot of ways.
And I think that, and I can trace so much
of my interest in science
and ultimately the way I do science
to the way my parents
encouraged my curiosity.
- And I assumed that
they were very supportive
generally, basically.
- Yeah, absolutely, absolutely.
I mean one of the things we
always did was go to museums.
And it was, you know just
our form of recreation,
museums, acuaria, things like that.
And I just remember, you know,
looking at museum exhibits
or seeing fish in the aquarium
and it would just capture my imagination
as a young kid, you know.
And it still does in some ways.
- And what about high school?
Any teachers before you
were off to college?
- Yeah, I had some really
excellent teachers in high school.
I was really fortunate that way.
What happened is actually
being in Philadelphia.
In 1976 I was about 10th or
11th grade, something like that,
and that was the
bicentennial celebrations,
and it was a very big
deal in Philadelphia.
And I had a history teacher
who wanted us to learn archeology.
And he was an amateur
archaeologist himself,
and he linked up with archeologists,
and we were working on archeology
from of the colonial days
and it just blew my mind.
That we can by digging in the dirt
learn something about our past, you know.
- So in a way you're sort
of piecing things together
that would prove useful later in life.
- Oh, there's no doubt, looking back,
that was so critical, you know.
- And undergraduate work?
- Yeah. undergrad, I went to
Columbia in New York City,
which was fortuitous in a lot of ways,
because there's the
great museum in New York,
the American Museum of Natural History
which was a venue that I
hung out and all the time.
I even had a little office
when I was an undergrad there.
There was a curator who basically
set me up with an office.
He saw I was a curious kid,
set me up with an office, a library card,
and keys to the collection.
And he didn't ask
anything of me other than
just go explore.
It was really remarkable,
what an opportunity that was.
But when I was at in college
I was interested in biology,
that's where I really got
interested in biology.
I was started with an
interest in archeology,
but then shifted to biology.
It soon became clear that
if I wanted to bridge
my interest in archeology
with my interest in biology,
paleontology, (chuckles)
not a bad way to go.
- And is that what you majored
in as an undergraduate?
- No, I majored in anthropology, biology,
and I minored in geology.
So there was no paleontology major,
I sorta cut and pasted a lot of stuff.
- And are you already seeing connections
or were connections being
made between these disciplines
as you took them as an undergraduate
and then as a graduate student?
- I see it in retrospect.
At the time I wasn't seeing it,
but definitely in retrospect
I see how those connections
were sitting probably in
my subconscious in some way
and influencing my behavior.
Because I was also very
interested in history as well,
American history, classical
history and things like that.
So all these different tendrils
were sort of coming together
in paleontology, evolutionary biology.
- And then on to graduate school,
and where did you do your graduate work?
- In Boston, at Harvard.
And I entered Harvard wanting
to work on fossil mammals
and understand how mammals
diversified, you know,
why if some mammals that climb trees,
others that dig, and so forth.
And then by about the second
year, switched to fish.
For a lot of reasons.
Fish and amphibians.
'Cause there are some fundamental problems
I wanted to get at.
And Harvard was another good choice,
because like Berkeley
actually, it's a big university
that has a museum embedded inside of it.
And so, again, it's linking
from museum to the laboratory,
that's always been
something that I've done
and cherished, actually.
You know, a museum has
always been important to me.
- It's interesting because when you think
of museums and libraries,
you don't think of
adventurers, which seems to
be a part of your personality
as we get into your work.
Or is that not fair, is
that not a fair statement?
- Well it's right to think on that way,
but I think that's a miss.
Because that's where the adventures begin.
The adventures begin opening
a cabinet in a museum,
seeing some specimens,
trying to figure out
the problems that those
specimens show you.
It begins in a library
where you're figuring out
where to work in the field and so forth.
So my starting point is
always a library or a museum
because they're revealing
to me the problems,
the puzzles, you know, that needs solving.
- And then, at Harvard,
what did you do your dissertation on?
- I worked on the
development and evolution
of the limb, arms and legs,
and I came up with a theory
of the relationship between
arms and legs and fins and fish.
So sort of the transformation
of fins to limbs.
Looking at embryology,
how organisms develop,
and looking at fossils,
so I was trying to link
my biology and paleontology interests.
- So let's talk about what
you are as a scientist.
I guess you are both an
anatomist and a paleontologist,
and so let's go down that road.
What are the skill sets that you think are
required to do these fields well?
- Well there's the personal skill set
and then there's the scientific skills,
intellectual skillset, I'll
call it intellectual, really.
The personal skill set is you
have to be pretty patient.
(chuckles)
You have to be able to
sort of sit with a problem
long enough to find an answer.
Curiosity helps, 'cause
that's what drives you
and that's the fuel, is
curiosity and has always been.
The intellectual skill
set I think really is
you know, understanding
the structure of the body.
Knowing the names of
the hulls and the bones
and the bumps and the nerves
and all that sort of stuff.
Knowing quite a bit about genetics
but that's sort of critical nowadays,
how genes are inherited
and how they specify
pattern and anatomy and so forth.
And basically I think the other big piece
of the skill set, and this
is just sort of generic,
is the willingness
and lack of fear
to enter new fields and
to learn new disciplines.
I mean, the way I look at my field
is not as a separate
silo, as one discipline.
I really look at it as a
puzzle or a problem to solve.
And if you look at it as a
puzzle or a problem to solve
different disciplines become tools to you.
And so if you can somehow figure out
how to gain access to
those tools even though
they might be in another
field like geology
or or chemistry or something like that,
you will be better off at the end and able
in your ability to solve your problem.
So I think one of the
most important things
particularly in today's science
is the ability and desire
to collaborate or learn
and extend one's toolkit
to different disciplines.
- You write in your book, you say,
"the unknown should not
be a source of suspicion,
fear, or retreat to superstition,
but motivation to
continue asking questions
and seeking answers".
So you really have to be comfortable
with moving across fields.
- And taking a leap into the unknown.
You know, when you set off an experiment
or a new expedition or something,
there's no guarantee of success.
There's a level of risk-taking
that's in this as well.
I mean, scientists are
always taking risks.
Sometimes for quite bold ones.
It is about finding answers to questions
and then ultimately, being
able to ask better questions,
(laughing) you know.
The questions don't stop,
they just get better
hopefully, or more refined,
hopefully, if you're successful.
I was a child of Apollo, the
rocket, not the Greek god.
(both laughing)
When I was 14, you know, 10 to 14,
that's when the missions
were going to the moon.
You know, that blew my mind.
That humanity can design a contraption
that takes people to the
moon and back, you know
and the ability to do that
still chokes me up to this day.
It's really cool.
- And in this context,
where do you see creativity?
How would you characterize creativity?
Is it something that that flows
from being on top of
all of these disciplines
and being comfortable with the tools
that you just described?
- Creativity comes to us, I
mean, it's hard to capture.
I think for me creativity
comes at the moments
when I'm able to throw off the constraints
of some of my previous
thinking, but not so much
that I'm not throwing
away to what I've learned.
You know what I'm saying?
It's it's sort of trying
to see things in a new way
that was that was sort of
invisible to me before.
Because of maybe mental traps I was in,
or preconceived notions that
are expectations that I have.
And the more I can get away from those ,
the more I can think in new ways
and do something truly creative, you know.
And so to me it really comes down to
trying to get rid of some
of your preconceived notions
and expectations and
always challenging them.
And we're not always good at that,
but I think that's how advances happened.
- Now you had a fellowship at Berkeley
or the Miller fellowship, and
I think you said yesterday
in your lecture that this was
a moment in your education
that was very helpful in
broadening your perspective
and looking at these problems in the way
that integrative biology does.
- Yeah, very much.
I mean, remember I said, you know,
when I see the world as a set of problems
and different disciplines
are tools to answer
and help tackle those problems.
When I dropped off in
Berkeley as a Miller fellow,
you know, here I was in
Berkeley with a bunch of people
who look the world the same way.
It was really remarkable.
And so I fed off their sort
of intellectual curiosity,
and energy, and interdisciplinary
approach to science
and intellectual questions.
- Now, you are doing your work
at a time when there really, just
many, many breakthroughs
across fields, basically.
And you talk about that.
So, it's an exciting time to be doing
what you're doing because of
the developments in genetics,
the developments in information
technology and so on.
- Hugely so.
I'm asking questions or able
to answer questions today
that I wasn't even thinking about
10 years ago, five years ago.
I mean the pace of change is so rapid.
Yet we're still, what's beautiful,
is to be able to apply new
techniques, new approaches
to sort of the classical problems,
the questions that have been around
for long periods of times,
that excited anatomist in the 1800's,
to be able to address those
fundamental questions.
That's where the real thrill is, you know.
And when you're able to do
that, it's just so satisfying.
- And in your book, you
talk about your experiences
and lecturing medical
students about human anatomy.
So this is, I would presume that
in a previous generation,
were paleontologists
teaching in medical school?
- Yeah, from time to time they were.
Yeah, it wasn't highly unusual.
In fact, as you know,
to be a paleontologist
you have to be a pretty good anatomist.
And you know, paleo anthropologists,
it's routine for them
to be involved in anatomy departments.
Fish paleontologists like
myself, or amphibian ones,
it's not as often.
But it's not that much of a stretch.
I remember when I started
teaching human anatomy
the students would come
to me and they'd say,
Dr. Shubin, what kind of doctor are you?
(both laughing)
Let's see, are you a surgeon
or are you a cardiologist or something?
I said, well, I'm a fish paleontologist.
He's like, I want my money back.
- A fish doctor
- Yeah, right, he's like,
I want my money back
or something like that.
But it became pretty clear,
as you can begin to teach the course,
that being a paleontologist,
an embryologist,
a fish paleontologist, in particular,
actually offers a nice
roadmap to the human body.
So became pretty, pretty
powerful actually.
- And now you, in your work, you have made
an important discovery and this came,
and we'll talk about that in a minute,
because at some point you
decided you were interested
in these periods of revolution in
the evolution of animals and man.
Talk about that interest
and where it came from.
- Sure, if you look at the history of life
there are certain moments
where it seems like
revolutions in the air, where
major changes are happening.
In the origin of body plans
or the origin of diverse kinds of fish,
the origin of different kinds
of creatures we call reptiles,
you know, things like that.
Seeing those periods helps me choose
the intervals to work
on as a paleontologist.
And so I work on Devonian age rocks,
which are rocks about 365 to
380 or so million years old,
of that portion of the Devonian.
And I do that because that's
when a lot of groups of fish
first came about,
including fish with legs.
And then also work on rocks
about 200 million years old,
because that's when
different kinds of creatures
we call reptiles came
about, including mammals
and crocodiles and dinosaurs
and all kinds of different
kinds of amphibians.
So, those have always attracted me
because when you run a field expedition
in one of those intervals,
there's always the chance
of finding something
that will tell you about one
of these great transformations,
these great transitions.
- You quote Eisenhower in your book
who said, "in preparing for battle,
I have found that planning is essential
but plans are useless".
- Yeah, 'cause there's always, I mean.
So take working in the
Arctic, for example.
I plan like crazy to work up there.
With my colleagues, you
know Ted and Garish,
who we planned together.
We plan the expeditions
down to the last candy bar.
You know, all the food goes
up there and everything.
- You better bring them, my guess,
'cause it's cold up there (both chuckling)
and the nearest town is not San Francisco.
- Exactly, and that's your
entertainment, you know.
So it's a good idea.
Yet, you know I make all these plans,
we do all this, and have move days,
and plan when the helicopters
are gonna get there
and so forth, but at some point
you have to throw the plans away,
because the facts on the
ground change everything.
You have to be flexible.
The weather, mechanical may be bad,
there may be mechanical problems.
You may discover something in one place
and want to stay there longer,
or not be discovering something in a place
you had high hopes for.
So you have to retain
a degree of flexibility
as the facts on the ground change.
And the only way you can be
effective and be flexible
is to plan like crazy, I
mean you need that sort of
knowledge of all the parameters
and planning helps you do that.
But you have to throw them away. (laughs)
- And you, and I want to
get the name right here,
your great breakthrough
was the discovery of tiktaalik,
a large freshwater fish
that had characteristics
that tell us it was a transitional figure
in the movement from fish to land.
Let's walk through that,
and in being interested
in these great periods of transformation
and you turn to geology first,
and geology tells you a lot
about where you want to look.
- Oh absolutely, I mean, we work at home,
in libraries, you know,
or on the internet,
or in the internet to
try to find places to go.
We have a time period in mind,
and the sort of the biggest parameter
to think about first is what age rocks
you're gonna work on.
And that's really kind of
what drove us to think about
finding tiktaalik, was that when we look
at what we knew about in the record
of fish evolving features
that allow their descendants
to walk on land, it came
out there's a sort of gap
in our knowledge in rocks
around 375 million years old.
So that sort of insight
was really critical.
Then it became clear
that we had to find rocks
of the right type, places in the world
that had rocks of the right
type to find fossil fish.
And then, you know, with
that screen or that filter
we would look at geological maps.
We would look at aerial photos
and then try to figure out where to go.
- And even college
textbooks for one thing.
- Well that's what I was saying,
so I applied all these great things,
and we were looking at geological
maps and all this stuff.
And had some ideas, but
the ultimate insight
that led to the discovery of tiktaalik
came from a college geology textbook
and showed me an area, and Ted Daeschler,
who I've been working with for years,
it showed me, it showed Ted and I,
an area we hadn't even
considered before. (chuckling)
- But in the beginning, with no budget,
you were actually, you had a
comparable area, fortunately,
in the state of Pennsylvania
where you were teaching.
- Yeah, exactly/
- So you could you could go
down the road, so to speak.
- Oh literally, yeah, and spend, you know,
20 bucks on a field
expedition driving from a car.
And that was productive,
but those rocks were sort
of too young to produce
a tiktaalik like creature.
We were already finding limbed animals
that were fairly far along.
- Right
- You know. and so we had to move back
about 10 million years in time
and that's when the search
for a new area began
in about the mid '90s.
And then we sort of ran into
this college geology textbook
during an argument, actually,
in my office in Philadelphia.
We ran into this
undergraduate geology textbook
and found that the Canadian Arctic
had enormous amounts of exposed
Rock of just the right age.
- Now it's very clear that
in your work serendipity,
is also at play, which
we haven't mentioned yet,
and when you chose the site
for the the kinds of formation of rocks,
which were accessible, and
the rocks were from the period
that you were interested in,
you had an undergraduate assistant
who began this discovery, in a sense,
by being late returning back to camp,
but tell us about that.
- Yeah, what happened was
we had a college student
who wanted to learn
paleontology named Jason Downs,
University of Pennsylvania
at the time, he was a senior.
And he came along with us.
Jason, he somehow got separated
from the team this day.
We all went back to prepare dinner,
it was around 7:00 and there was no Jason.
And that's a worry.
When someone gets separated
and dinner rolls around,
and you're not seeing them,
that's when you begin to
worry if they're in trouble.
Maybe they hurt themselves,
sprained their ankle somewhere.
The Arctic's a big place, and
if they're if they're hurt
it would be a challenge.
- And you actually go out
on your own, basically.
- Well, we usually go out in groups of two
that was the weird thing about this.
I mean, you're not
supposed to get separated.
And Jason got separated.
- I see.
- And so we were beginning to worry
and then we heard footsteps,
you know coming to the tent.
(vocalizing zipping)
Tent opens up and there's Jason.
His eyes are like orbs,
you know. (chuckles)
He's out of breath.
We worried that Jason's being chased
by a polar bear or what have you.
But the real reason became clear
why he was so excited and late
was every pocket of
his parka and his pants
was filled with fossil fish bones.
What happened is during that absence
he had discovered a
layer of rock that was,
contained like a carpet
of fossil fish bones.
So then, you know after talking to Jason,
after he'd calmed a bit and
told us where the area was,
we decided, it's the Arctic,
it's daylight 24 hours a day,
You know, dinner can wait.
We grab the candy bars. (chuckles)
And off we went to Jason's little site.
To look for the layer and try to map it.
And it took us a while to find the layer,
took quite a while, actually.
And then when we did, it
turns out it was skeleton.
And that layer was produced by,
That layer of fish bone
fragments was produced by,
skeleton after skeleton of fossil fish
weathering out of the rocks.
So it was really neat.
- And, the discovery was
made on a subsequent trip?
You went back, yeah.
- Yeah, several years later, actually.
Nothing happened easy there.
It took us about six
years to find tiktaalik.
It took us a while to really hone in.
Jason's site, we had to
work it for two years
before we found anything really important.
- And was your fish
found at that same site?
Yeah, right.
And so what, do you
demarcate the site and then
it remains secure during these?
- Yeah, you're in the
middle of nowhere, yeah.
You're in the middle of
nowhere, nobody's gonna
see, find it.
They'd have to really spend a ton of money
and time to get to it.
And it's also specialized.
There's no, really, there's no fear
of somebody working that site and finding
and they'd have to know,
really, some detailed geology.
I could take someone
to that site right now
and show it to them, and
they still wouldn't know
where the layers, you know.
You have to work there for a while
to really get the nuance of what the rock
and, what the difference
between rock and fossil is,
and so forth.
- So the discovery is
made in the sense that,
hey, this is a place to look, over time,
and then the, on the return
trips, you're carefully
digging in to go down.
- And so you're exposing
it as a big platform
a flat bed, if you will.
And on that bed were skeletons,
some partial, some complete,
you know, some on top of one another,
some mushed against each other.
And as we did it, we
weren't finding anything,
you know, truly important.
I mean, they were interesting,
they're telling us something
about the ecosystem,
but it took us a while, there
was a lot of frustration.
You know, and part of it, you
know, part of this serendipity
taking over here is
being persistent enough
to let that happen.
- [Harry] I see, right.
- You know, and we made
the conscious decision
to stick on this site for a period of,
a long period of time.
You know, several years.
We, in fact, the year we
ended up finding tiktaalik,
which was 2004, I remember a conversation
three months before we went to the field
with Ted and Garish,
really starting asking the question,
do we really want to go this year?
I mean, have we done it enough?
And we all decided no,
no, one more go, you know.
And that's.
- Now what you're finding on the top,
is it different kinds of fishes
or pieces that you can't
make anything out of it?
And as you go down, are you going
into earlier or different
years, basically in the layers?
- This is actually one layer.
And so we expose that one
single layer as a giant bed.
And it's all kinds of
different species of fish.
There may be 10 to 15 species of fish
coming out of this layer.
None of them horribly
novel for that time period.
You know, and so we're
finding lots of fish,
and lots of different species of fish,
but nothing like
tiktaalik, nothing at that,
part of the Tree of Life, you know.
- But they are all from the same period?
- Yeah
- Basically?
Now in finding them and saying,
oh there's, you know, X,
or oh there's Y,
that propels you forward
because it's telling you
that the question mark
may be somewhere there.
- Yeah, exactly, and then
when we, once we know
what tiktaalik looks like,
and that gives you confidence
that when you go somewhere else
your eye will be a little more trained
to find it if it's there.
Then we have it from a
couple other sites as well.
- Now how did you know what
tiktaalik would look like?
You hypothesized it, yeah.
- Basically, if you look at the transition
from a low fin fish to
an early limbed animal,
you know, you'll see,
you go from a creature
with a conical head with
eyes on either side,
and the lobe finned fish?
These early limbed animals
so a flathead sort of thing
with eyes on top.
There're other changes as well.
So we knew if we had a
flat-headed fish with scales
it was gonna be really interesting.
That's exactly what we found,
saw for the first time,
and that's when we knew we had tiktaalik.
when we saw a flat-headed
fish, it was very serious.
- And how did, can you
talk about that moment
when you saw him and
what were your feelings?
- Well they're really beautiful
and we discovered several of them,
on the forth day of that season,
that we almost decided not to go on.
And, my colleague Steve
Gatsey is a professor at Brown
was working with us that year.
And we were working Jason's
site, cracking rocks.
And Steve says hey guys, what's this?
And we all sort of ran up.
And, the head of a flat
headed fish, just sticking
right out of the side
of the hill, you know.
At that moment, we knew, it was exactly
what we were looking for.
We didn't know how much of
the skeleton would be there,
but we knew it was the exact creature.
It was really, that moment was remarkable
because it took us six
years to get to that point.
Six years of blood, seat
and tears in the Arctic.
You know, it's hard working
there, both personally
and physically and financially.
You know, you name it.
And so everybody who was involved
in the project from the start,
who saw it at that point,
it was a huge moment for us.
The there was a (giggles), that moment
went to panic, however, because
getting the rock fossils
out of the Arctic,
particularly heavy things
and big things like titaalik.
I mean titaalik, the biggest specimens are
about nine feet long, is no small matter.
And our worry shifted,
not how we are gonna
find these things, to how are we gonna
get them out of the rock and back home,
because that year we
had really bad weather.
Pretty much every day it
snowed or sleeted on us
- Everyday and it's not
really conducive for,
- [Harry] Yeah
- glue working on things or plasters
and the traditional methods we use.
- So is the idea that you take the whole
area around the fish out, yeah?
- Wrap it in plaster
and then back it comes.
- [Harry] And transport it, is that also
a concern, I take it?
- Yeah, 'cause then I need the helicopter.
And so, that's why it has to be, you know.
It goes a long way in a sling underneath
the helicopter or sometimes in the bed
of the helicopter in the back seat,
but nestled in seat belts and, you know.
And it's a long helicopter ride
and bumpy and so forth.
- [Harry] So you had one?
- No, that first year we had 1, 2, 3, 4.
- But on this spotting and this siting
- That day
- That day, so you were able
to take several back with you?
- The next day we found another one
and about three days later
we found another one.
It was like boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
Really rapid and it just was,
that week was just incredible,
because we knew we had wonderful material.
- At the site are you
carving him out of the rock
or are you carving the rock and taking
the whole magillah out?
- Taking the whole magillah home.
- Oh, yeah.
- We don't carve them
out of the rock there.
That is in the laboratory.
Done under very controlled circumstances.
You know, we're basically
bringing a bid boulder home.
- With bones sticking out of it.
And we just leave it.
If the bone is showing,
we've already done too much,
(chuckling) you know?
And so we just try to
lightly work around it.
Leaving a safety margin.
And you don't always get it right,
sometimes you do crack
a bone and so forth.
- [Harry] Um hm
- But that's okay, and
then you rough it out
and back it comes to the laboratory.
It takes about a month
and a half to get home.
- Now, I wanna understand how
this discovery confirmed everything
that you knew about where to
look and the king of rock.
So this kind of rock was one that was,
such that the skeleton would
be partially visible, yeah?
- These rocks were formed
in an ancient delta system.
Part of the margins or the
bank of an ancient stream
or a point bar, or some area that would
collect the skeletons as they washed
down the stream in a flooding event
or something like that.
And they were rapidly buried.
That's a classic environment,
fossil environment
for preserving really nice bones.
- [Harry] Mm hm
- So it was clearly an ancient river
and the margin of an ancient river.
And this geologies perfect for that,
to find lots of, and
there're other species
that are coming out of those rocks.
- How did tiktaalik get his name?
- Well what happened
- [Harry] or her name?
- I have no idea, his, her or whatever
- Yeah (chuckles)
- I don't know.
When we found this creature, you know,
in the scientific paper it's
our job to give it a name,
a generic and a specific name.
And we wanted the name to be meaningful
to the Inuit community.
There was a Inuit community
about 200 miles away,
that was giving us
permits to work up there.
We involved some of their youth
in our field expeditions at the time.
And we felt pretty connected to them.
And we wanted them to feel involved
in the project and in
our work and so forth.
So we worked with the Inuit
traditional knowledge elders.
And we talked to them,
to come up with a name
that is meaningful to them and to us
and a name that we could pronounce.
Now, Inuktitut is a
very difficult language
on the English speaking tongue.
And so that was not an
easy thing. (chuckles)
Those two parameters weren't always easy.
And so tiktaalik is their
word for fresh water fish.
And the name stuck and the
species name is roseae, so.
- So you take the tiktaalik
back to the laboratory
and what do you find?
Help us understand why this was
such an important story
that made the cover,
the front page of the New York Times.
- Right, so, I wasn't the first person
to see the beautiful material.
Neither was Ted or any of the other
senior scientists on the project.
It was the fossil preparator.
They're the talented people who
literally sit with a needle and a pin vice
under a microscope, removing
the rock grain by grain.
Now they can do this because the bone
is harder than the rock.
'cause the bone's kind of petrified.
So there's a separation between the two.
And so they use like little mini
dental tools and pins and
so forth, over months.
So we brought these things back
and Fred Mullison in Philadelphia,
Bob Masek in Chicago worked for months
removing the rock from the bone.
- [Harry] Are these different fish
that they're working on, or
- [ Other] Different titaalik specimens.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And so Bob was, we have a dinosaur lab
in Chicago that's really big so we had
the big specimens of titaalik in Chicago.
There's a smaller lab in Philidelphia,
they're specialized for smaller stuff
and so Fred was working
on the material there.
And over a period of
months, tiktaalik gradually
revealed itself, you know.
First we saw the flat
head with the eyes on top
Then we saw that tiktaalik has a neck
then we saw the body with the scales
on its back and fins, with fin webbing.
Then Bob took apart one of the fins,
took the fin webbing off.
And in it we found, you
know, bones that correspond
to shoulder, elbow and wrists.
- [Harry] Mm hm
- You know, over a
period of 5, 6, 7 months,
this creature starting revealing itself
as sort of a mosaic between fish
and land living, limbed animal.
- [Harry] Mm hm
- You know, if I was to hold
it in front of you right now,
you would see is a creature
about four feet long.
One of the smaller specimens.
And you'd look at it and, you know,
you'd see it has scales on its back
and fins with fin webbing.
You'd say, ah, fish.
Until you looked at the head.
You'd see it has a crocodile like,
almost flat head with
eyes on top, has a neck.
No fish has a neck.
Then you'd see those limb bones
that start to look awfully limb like.
Has big fat ribs.
So it has this sort of mix between,
the characteristics of the
land living animals and fish.
Found at just the right
time in the fossil record
at around 375 million years ago,
when we'd expect this
transition to be happening.
- So, this discovery,
I wanna go, I'm fascinated
by the way in which
all these things come together
So, you're training.
Your knowledge of geology tells you
which rocks to look in
and where to go.
And your bringing all
your expertise to bear,
but an undergraduate who
happens to be on the team
discovers the site
- Isn't that great
- Yeah, yeah (both laughing)
and your perseverance
says, oh, let's go back again at a time
when you're debating whether to do that.
- Exactly, and you know,
but you bring your crew,
each with different skills.
And by the way, you have to cover
a lot of turf up there
- So you need a bunch of people looking,
different kinds of eyes and so forth.
- By the way, Jason Downs, who was
the undergraduate when this was found
is now a post doctoral
fellow in paleontology.
So he stuck with it.
- [Harry] So he stuck
with it, yeah. (laughing)
Having started off on a high note, yeah.
So he decided to go on.
So, back to the fish.
So, he has a neck, he or she has a neck.
And you can trace out the wrist, the ribs
and other parts, basically.
And I guess you can say he's an athlete.
He does a kind of push up.
- [Neil] Yeah
- Tell us about that and
why that's important.
- Well
- I'm being foresetious,
I should tell you.
- Sure, so titaalik is an animal that
can support itself on its fins.
That's pretty clear.
- I mean appendage support
is pretty prominent
and they could flex at the elbow,
extended sort of the wrist area,
the equivalent of the wrist.
It has big pectoral muscles,
so it could definitely
sort of push itself up.
For an animal that's supporting
itself on its appendages,
it's a good thing they had a neck.
Fish don't have necks
because if they want to move
their eyes or mouth in
space they just swim around.
They're moving in three dimensional space.
But the minute you become
fixed to the ground
or the substrate, all of the sudden,
if you want to look around, the
neck becomes very important.
So the neck is tied to
having head mobility,
to move the head, eyes and
mouth, while the creature
is fixed on the ground.
So you see this corelation
among the origin
of different features in
titaalik for the first time.
It's really remarkable
because you're seeing
a creature that's specializing for life
in the shallows, you know.
Still in water
- tiktaalik has both lungs and gills.
You know, it's ah, but
it's able to support itself
on the water bottom in
the shallows and maybe
for short periods in the
mud flats and so forth.
- Do you speculate as to why
it needed to make this
move and then adapted?
- Yeah, so it's, if you look at the,
compare water to land at this time period,
water is loaded with predictors,
loaded with competitors.
It's a pretty, you know,
fish eat fish world
in these streams that we find titaalik in.
It's living with some
10 - 15 feet long fish
that are big and nasty.
On land, you have some
of the earliest forests,
you have large arthropods and vertebrates,
but no competitors for
titaalik and its descendants.
So, you know, you compare and contrast.
Land is actually free of competitors,
free of predictors, as apposed to water.
So their may be some
influence of getting away
from the fight, if you
will, a hostile environment,
onto land and onto rich food sources,
which exist on land as well.
There's another kind of explanations,
which I'm not really, you know,
these are not mutually exclusive.
That is the notion that perhaps
rising oxygen levels towards the end of
the Devonian and later
had something to do with
creatures evolving on land and evolving,
sort of more of a
reliance on air breathing.
- How long did it take for
this fish to become what
it was, do you think
in its relation to its
ancestor that had not
yet become distinctively
what titaalik was?
- Oh, I'd say you're
probably looking about
7 million years and then probably another
10, oh, probably another
7 to 10 million years
before you get real,
creatures with real fingers
and things like that, that
are real limbed animals.
- So it's a pretty long
period of time, actually.
It didn't happen fast.
At least according to
the data we have now.
Now, in talking about this
discovery you've helped us
understand how this, you're
working across disciplines
and about how all these
disciplines are informing
where you go, what you see, what you find
and the conclusions you reach.
In your book, The Inner
Fish, you also talk about
breakthroughs in genetics
and our understanding of DNA
that essentially allows people like you,
doing this kind of work
to see our relation
to living animals.
To come to an understanding of
how they come to be what they are
and their relation to us, on the one hand,
but also some of the same mechanisms
may have been a work in this prehistory.
Talk a little about that.
- Sure, you can put it really
simply and ask the question.
Look at the genetic and
developmental recipe
that builds the body of
a lone living animal,
like an amphibian and look at the genetic
and developmental recipe that builds
the body of a fish.
And then you can ask the simple
question to compare with.
What's the different
between those two recipes,
Or among many more recipes?
- To get to the notions is,
what are the differences,
the genetic differences between, sort of
the genetic recipe that
builds a limb from a fin.
- Are they major, are
they minor, do you have to
involve whole new sets of genes
to have limb come on board?
And so that's sort of the motivation
when you get to the
understanding living creatures
and their genetics and
development and so forth.
When you look at this in more detail
- And you look at the
genetic, sorta tool kit
that builds an appendage
Whether it's a limb or a fin,
they're actually similar.
And what that's suggesting
in a very powerful way,
is that much of the machinery that builds
the skeleton of a limb is already
presence in the fin of a fish.
Sharks, killios fish, things like
trout and salmon and
those sorts of things.
And they're distant relatives.
They all have the essential tool kit
that builds a limb in place.
Now there're subtle
differences between them,
but there're not huge
differences between them.
So that's sort of the take
home message we're seeing.
Now we're trying to get to say,
well what are these subtle differences
and how did fingers arise from those
sort of, the bones we call
radials in a fish fin.
- And you can look at genes in the genome
in particular animals and
essentially experiment
in the lab with living to see how you,
what triggers the different mechanisms
to make the substantial changes.
- Exactly, and we can
manipulate the embryos
and we can look at how
those, what are the switches
that turns those genes on and off.
How those switches, how do they compare
between fish and a limbed animal.
And we can ask all those
questions with great power now.
Oh, and lots of different
kinds of species.
So it's a really great time
to work on all these things.
- And you're saying that the
great evolutionary transformation did not
involve new DNA, it's really something
getting turned on or off and, as a result
creating a new direction.
- Yeah, basically, you
know, using existing genes
in new ways is sorta the idea.
Redeploying them,
different times and places
And so, yeah, it didn't
involve necessarily
a great genetic revolution.
It's using existing materials.
And when you think about that and that
this transformation in the fossil record,
happened over tens of millions of years,
and the fact that, likely the genetic
tool kit that makes the
bodies of limbed animals
is already present in
large state, in fish,
this transition becomes easy to happen
and the question becomes
why didn't it happen
a zillion times, why
did it only happen once.
- And sometimes this
doesn't work in the sense
that we humans wind up
with products of evolution
that we could do without.
I use the example of, hiccups
and hernias, actually.
- Hernias a great one, yeah.
If you'd look at a human male, I mean,
it makes no sense and it's,
probably to nobody's surprise
that it makes least
sense in the genital area
because the way the
spermatic cord, you know,
connects the testis or the vas deferens
inside the spermatic
cord, connect the testis
to the penis is this bizarre
loop its taken, you know,
and it takes a bizarre course.
It doesn't take the direct
route from scrotum to penis.
It goes up and around
the bowl of the pelvis
and down through the hole
of the pelvis, if you will.
And it's that loop and
the formation of that loop
that causes a human males problems.
They're more susceptible to certain kinds
of hernias than females.
And the reason for that is,
we begin our development
like a fish, with the
gonads, the primordial
for the gonads up here towards the kidneys
and the chest, and they descend over time
towards the scrotum.
In the females the
ovaries descend as well,
but just not as far 'cause they don't lie
in the out pocket of the body wall.
And it's that formation,
that descend of the testis,
which creates a weakness
in the male body wall.
And so you can have
hernias that develop during
the development of that
descent of the testis
in infants or you can have it in adults
where there's a weakness in the body wall
and portions of the gut
cavity get pushed through.
- You write in your book that great ideas
begin with simple promises.
And one simple idea that you're saying
is driving your work is that all of us
are modified descendens of our parents.
And that brings a clarity
to how all of this,
that we've been talking about happens.
- Yeah, and that's Charles Darwin.
One of the main ideas in Charles Darwin's
origin of species is
descent with modification.
That is we all modify
descendens of our parents
and we have a family
tree in our own families.
But our family tree
extends to other species.
And our species is a modified descendants
of the ancestorial species
that we've come from.
And if you look at the world in a pattern
of descendants with
modification, you see the world
in to form of an evolutionary tree,
where features can be traced over millions
and billions of years to their ancestors.
- Now what is one left
with when one realizes,
obviously, it's a wonderful insight,
but how has it effected you're thinking
about humanities place
in the universe that we live in?
- I mean, it's impossible not to see this
and not to feel an
experience in a powerful way,
the connection that we have to the rest
of life on our planet.
I mean, in our genes and
our bodies and everything.
I mean, this is sort of written in the
Nobel Prize's Medicine of Physiology.
I mean, if you look at the Nobel Prize's
Medicine or Physiology in the last, what,
17 years, who have they gone to?
Well, they've gone to
people working on flies,
people working on worms, people working on
sea urchants, yeasts, sea slugs, corn.
And all these are work on
other creatures to provide
insight about human health.
So I'd like to think as we discover cures
or treatments for things that ail us
like Alzheimer and
various types of cancers,
those treatments or cures will ultimately
be derived from work originally done
on flies and worms and
yeast and sea urchants.
I mean can you imagine a more powerful way
to state our deep connection to the rest
of life on our planet than that?
And that's all because
of the evolutionary tree.
You know, the descendants
with modification
that Darwin was talking about.
- Now how do you think that the mans power
over technology will effect our evolution?
I mean, are we gonna
see unbelievable changes
where in a sense, we are impacting
these processes that you've
discovered in far away times?
- We are, I mean, our culture,
our society social structure, the gizmos
and technologies we devise,
whether it's our medicines
or machines that enhance
our performance, our lives,
that effect the way we see the world
and interact and behave and so forth.
Those kinds of structures are very much
gonna influence our future in a great way.
Much more than our genes, right?
I mean, that doesn't say
that our genetic evolution
isn't happening and continually happening
and is not important.
Just look at the threats
of infectious disease
that we face.
We're at a continual war with microbes.
But sometimes we're able to mediate that
with our medications, but
we're, at a Darwinian level
we're still evolving, very much so
and we're still at war, if you will
with the bugs that are around us.
And we're not always at war, it's we're in
a sinbiotic relationship
with many of them as well.
But our technologies are gonna
influence our performance.
And they already are in so many ways.
You know, look at doping scandals
and bicycling and baseball.
Look at the technologies that can enhance
human memory and muscle mass
and all basic parameters
of what we are, you know.
So, you come back in 500 years, I mean.
Human performance will be
driven largely, I think
by social structures and technologies
that enhance them.
- Does these discoveries in
these fields that you work in,
in what way do they interface with the
global warming problem, if any at all?
I mean, is it just that we get a sense of
how it all, sorta fits together
and that at a certain point man has to
draw a line as to what it wants to do
in certain directions least
it harm the environment?
- Well, on the fossil record we see
the influence of global warming.
We see the influence of
global change in general
on faunas and floras and
extinctions and so forth.
I mean, there's a finely tuned balance
between changes in the
climate and the atmosphere
and the kinds of life and their
distribution on our planet.
What's challenging here
is the rate of change
is not something we've
been able to measurer
in the kind of fossil record
that I work on, easily.
And so, it doesn't lend
us the predictive power
in the kinds of challenges
we're gonna face
as a society as a result
of our own activities.
- Looking at, reflecting
on your career now,
how would you advise
students who are interested
in this stuff to prepare for the future?
I mean, obviously become, develop skills
and a lot of discipline,
you've been saying.
- Yeah, but it starts
with the liberal arts.
It really does.
You know, a good liberal
arts education can't be beat.
You need it.
It's an essential.
Reading, writing, the
classics, literature,
history, science, I mean
just a liberal education
is the centerpiece for all
of this because that provides
the grounding for your curiosity.
- Knowing, having a background that's
sophisticated enough so that you know
where to look when you have a question
becomes so important.
And not having fear, you
know to admit ignorance
and ask a colleague and
go into a new field.
I always encourage
students to be aggressive
with their professors and their teachers.
And sit and say, look I'm
interested in this stuff.
What do I need to know,
how do I do it, you know.
And they'll often be your best advisors.
- How do think that, let's go back to your
medical school class 'cause,
How do you think you, with this background
have informed them
and essentially, in
some way impacted their
educational experience and the way
they think about the
human body as a result of
the broader perspective
that you bring to anatomy?
- Well I like to think that, you know,
at best my aspiration,
let's put it that way,
is that they look at the
human body in a different way.
Now they are in medical school
for a very particular reason.
They need to know the
structures of the body
and they need to have that tool kit,
but along with that, I'd also love them
to have a appreciation of how important
understanding our connections
to the rest of life
are to understanding the human body.
And I know for some medical students
that's been very important.
They've emailed me and
we've talked about it
and you know, everybody's different.
But, at least my aspiration
is absolutely that
knowing the connections we
have with the rest of life
on our planet, not only tells us about
the structures of our body,
but the ways our bodies
are unintelligently
designed and they fall apart
from time to time.
- Well on that note, Neil,
I wanna thank you very much
for being here.
Let me show your book.
Your Inner Fish, which
is a fascinating read
for young and old and
it really gives a sense
of what your field is
up to and the remarkable
discoveries that you
and your team have made.
Thank you very much.
- Thanks for having me.
- And thank you very much for joining us
for this Conversations With History.
(upbeat music)